Alo ạ
anh đợi mình một tí ạ
ở tập bớt mấy cái tuần này giá
Chào bạn
ờ ờ trước khi bắt đầu thì mình xin phép
cho các bạn xem
video Mình vừa mới xem ờ khá là giải trí
kết hợp với việc là mình sẽ nói lý do
sau khi các bạn có xem chữ đã khá giải
trí
không nhận cảm đâu không thể cảm đâu
bộ
phim mà
Không được mua em không phải em đâu phải
là em ngày hôm nay chị mặc quần áo Em
điện hỏi em nhé Thì bây giờ là em đi
uống rượu đúng không Thế thôi em Cố quay
quay lưng mà người ta để cho người ta
nhìn thấy tấm lưng trần của em à đúng
không Nhưng sẽ về đây tìm thấy lưng của
em trước em không gặp bác ơi anh muốn
được
số này mới gặp ngay xong thì mình nhận
ra là mình có thể có thể đánh giá chung
về quần áo cô Phương Anh để đặt xe như
cái chỗ Không cần che và hở nhưng có chỗ
không cần khẩu mà mình nó lại xe đến số
không cần xe và hưởng những chỗ không
cần hỏi thêm câu nữa Dạ vâng mặc quần áo
mà không hở thì phí tiền nó chưa là em
mình có những cái cần nên biết Tưởng nó
cũng khá là không khóa như em đã nói từ
ban đầu video rất phòng quá một phụ nữ
phóng khoáng đường Cảm ơn mọi người đã
xem hết video Ừ nếu mà một người thì hãy
đi sau video này một like và hãy sức sau
đây của Đặng Thu Hà Gia Lâm và
anh alo bạn
ờ ờ
nhà mình có nốt ở đây một tí đó là
Ừ thế này của Facebook à Tôi cũng web
thì không biết tôi vào ngon
em à có có có ok
ở nhà mình xin phép nói qua video Rồi
trước à
cho video âm nhạc
à mà xem lúc gặp video hỏi nữa đi video
này nữa có cái đoạn mình muốn
đi học Bạn xem từ đoạn này
à à
ở tạm tâm sự thư giãn một tí trước khi
bắt đầu nhé
[âm nhạc]
cái khoảnh khắc nào mà một người phát
hiện ra là mình không phù hợp với công
nghiệp này
mình chẳng có khoảnh khắc nào nó này
mình là một quá trình nhưng mình nghĩa
mình nói mình thường Ôi mình có thể kiểm
soát tất cả công việc và mình có thể làm
được rất là nhiều việc cùng một lúc tí
một người video này video này Thực ra
cũng là một cái video mà một ngày rất là
bận mình
nhưng không biết làm gì nó quay hết được
không nhưng mà trông là hôm nay cũng là
một ngày rất bận và mình sẽ đã dậy từ 5
rưỡi sáng nên là bây giờ hơi gì một tí
nhưng mà nói mình đã từng nghĩ là mình
có thể kiểm soát được công việc đấy Cái
lượng công nghiệp như vậy nhưng mà cho
đến khi mà mình Anh Huy nói mình làm
giờ này trong này xét quá chắc là mình
nhìn mà cứ nó không thích tục hoàn toàn
được nữa có nên chuyện mà nó ra bình
thường nhưng mà mình nhìn vào mình lại
cảm thấy rất là căng thẳng em rất là
buồn bực cho nên làm
mình nó cũng nhìn lại và mình đã xem lại
xem là mình đã phải nhìn lại quãng thời
gian đấy là tại sao à Sao Bây giờ mình
lại tiêu cực như này thì phát hiện ra là
mình mình
không biết lượng sức mình nhé mình ôm
Quá nhiều thứ nhưng có nhiều được mà
việc nào mình cũng muốn lần nó phải thật
là hoàn hảo nó phải ít nhất là nó không
được điểm 10 thì nó ngoài được từng bệnh
ấy thì sau này mình cầm đi nên quá tải
mình có biết là video này có được lên 20
điểm nhấn nó không nó sử dụng ok thì
mình ngồi sau lên đấy thì mình không
biết là nó có lên được cái video này hay
không Nhưng mà nếu mà các bạn đang xem
được video này thì có nghĩa là mình nó
quyết tâm này phát triển những câu cá
nhân thì ra ở cuối video này ảnh Thì
mình định là sẽ đưa trong cái thông điệp
gì đấy là một lời khuyên nào đó dành cho
các bạn đang xem thế nhưng mà chính bản
thân mình đây cũng đang chưa thoát khỏi
cái vòng luẩn quẩn hết như là nó cũng
không dám nói gì cả Mình chỉ muốn khuyên
các bạn là Hãy cứ thủ đi mình còn trẻ mà
hãy thử tất cả những gì mình muốn và sau
đó thì các bạn sẽ biết là các bạn phù
hợp với công việc như thế nào và mình
không biết là sự lựa chọn của mình sau
này nó cả đúng hay không thì nhưng mà
ngay tại thời điểm này thì mình nghĩ là
thế là sự lựa Khi mà mình rồi Chào mừng
các bạn đã đến với kênh YouTube của mình
ta luôn giúp mọi người Mình sẽ chăm sóc
cho nó đến khi nào mà không thể nữa thì
thôi và các bạn hãy rất qua cho kênh của
mình nhá giờ thì thích
kiểu cho xem nhắn qua cái video bạn đấy
không không hẳn ở về nội dung của cả một
cái video mà chính xác là cái đoạn mà
cậu bạn đấy tóm tắt ở cuối video
gì để nói về cậu dạng là với kênh bạn
đấy này và cảm Nói chung là Tóm tắt cảm
nhận cái thứ thứ sau cả video đấy
Ừ thì như các bạn thấy con rồi Nó là một
kênh cá nhân là kiểu dạng là cũng mang
thiên hướng Vlog Và chắc là về sau mình
cũng có thể tham khảo mình cũng sẽ bắt
chước kiểu ngày có thể mình cả quay
không được chuyên nghiệp kiểu như thế
cũng mình sẽ xem cân nhắc khá nhiều với
mấy cái vụ đấy cũng như Nói chung là ở
có rất nhiều cách kì quay và rất nhiều
cách để mà chèn vào tôi cũng xem một vài
video về kiểu du lịch ở bên Nhật thì gần
như là không có tiếng gì cả không một
chính xác là không một tiếng nói mà chỉ
có phụ đề trong đấy à
à Tôi nghĩ là sẽ còn nói gì à Ừ tôi nói
hay hơn kiểu tôi viết văn nhưng lại rất
sáng tôi sẽ nói và Nhưng mà nói thì có
thể là có hai kiểu 1 loa kiểu nói ngay
Tải video hay ở lồng bàn hoặc bà ba là
cả hai nhưng mà tôi sẽ cân nhắc về vụ
đấy Nói chung hợp kênh của tôi vẫn sẽ
hưởng về sau có thể đã kéo
vị inox kiểu na ná như vừa rồi cũng nêu
vài cảm nhận các thứ thứ vì thế khó ổi
video của bạn đấy Mấy hôm nay tờ Tôi mới
xem thôi chứ không phải là hồi trước xem
thì phần là xinh à
anh thì thấy em một Visa cũng tầm mười
mười phút thấy khá hợp lý đẹp hả xem để
mà
bí thư giãn là nhiều hơn là đương nhiên
là cũng ah
Ừ tự nhiên là cũng kiểu có thêm một vài
cái góc nhìn Nhưng mà thường chủ yếu thư
giãn
ai ngờ video của tôi về sau sẽ không hả
hướng thư giãn kiểu như thế Cái đấy để
tôi xem xem video đầu tay của mình nên
là như thế nào đã
khi người Nhật thì kiểu người ta cũng
muốn ít nói kiểu và đã cả cái đấy có một
điểm hay Nó là kiểu rạp phụ đề đấy ông
làm ạ đa ngôn ngữ được còn việc ông nói
ông sẽ chỉ nói nó cũng ngôn ngữ một thời
điểm thôi đúng không ạ
anh Bởi vì tận 4 phút nè chả tối không
mở trong mày ông xem được nhưng mà tôi
kiểu ghi nốt lại để cho mày ông xem kiểu
thì mày không biết Qua được là thức A
đến hôm qua tôi mới biết rồi Tôi cũng
không tôi biết về anh đen nhưng mà không
anh không cậu hâm mộ thì cậu rất là cùng
nhiệt cũng nhờ không tìm hiểu thì mấy
người ca sĩ à Nói chung mà mình hơi bị
gọi nhà không để ý Sao biết à Cái thứ
thứ Thì hôm qua mới mới xem được về cái
á
về việc là anh ấy 755 lộn mưu sinh này
với nghề công nhân vệ sinh môi trường tự
nhiên là là
Ừ chắc chắn ở cũng có thể phóng đại gì
đó Bởi vì trong video cũng có đề cập là
cho anh đấy trong 7 năm này làm tại cái
cục nơi quản lý này và nhiều lúc cô cũng
không phải làm công nhân vệ sinh mà có
thể làm những cái khác nữa Nhưng đúng là
cũng chủ yếu là công việc này cũng đưa
như là cũng vất vả và và thời đấy con
được cũng kiểu anh ấy cũng bắt đầu ráp
và cũng kiểu rằng là cũng có phỏng vấn
thứ rồi anh ấy không nghĩ là sẽ có ngày
hôm nay sẽ sẵn rồi và nhưng mà cái cách
nói chuyện của anh đấy Nó là kiểu à
Anh nói là anh đẩy rất là may mắn khi mà
kiểu hả Được được như bây giờ bởi vì
kiểu Thời đấy cũng phát bây giờ cũng rác
thải ra anh ấy bảo là rác của anh ấy
Thời đấy Em bây giờ không khác gì nhau
chẳng qua là bây giờ thì được mọi người
biết đến hơn thì tắt cả hai phát
à Tôi đang làm vụ in ấn in in lót chuột
đấy nhớ chuột cho bé hôm nay
xe offline sẽ là mùng 9 tháng 10 bây giờ
chốt là như thế chắc là sẽ vào buổi
chiều à
Ừ chiều chủ nhật mùng 9 tháng 10 thì
em à Đang nói dở đâu nhỉ thì nói chung
là anh ấy hiểu
kiểu dạng là anh ấy bạn là mình lúc đấy
chắc chắn là chưa suy nghĩ gì cả và cứ
tiếp tục phấn đấu tiếp tục sống tiếp tục
cầu ở cống hiến và sẽ có một ngày của nó
chắc chắn là kiểu gì sẽ có một ngày khá
hơn chả qua là cũng rất may mắn để được
như bây giờ nhưng mà khi mà người ta khi
mà người ta Tôi thường anh nói với ông ở
tôi được như bây giờ một phần là một vỉa
Tôi từng sống cuộc sống kẹo cũng chả có
cái gì để mất cả nên thành ra tôi cứ cục
phấn đấu và cư kiểu
em ở nhà cứ hết mình nếu tôi không ngồi
nghĩ nhiều người hay bị nghĩ về việc ở
tủi thân anh ngày anh cũng chưa phải anh
cũng có lúc tủi thân nhưng mà hắn chửa
vẫn tiếp tục làm được tiếp tục kiểu dạng
nhà
ờ ờ cứ đâm đầu bắt đầu vào công việc đã
thử thử anh ấy bảo là 75 Nếu mà nhìn lại
nói một quãng thời gian
áo dài nhưng mà trong thời gian đấy thì
thì chúng ta đâu Cảm nhận được đâu thì
giống cái mọi ngành nghề cũng thế nghĩa
là kiểu thời gian đầu bắt đầu làm thì sẽ
thấy ra khó và gian nan và kiểu nghe
hiểu phải nghỉ mấy năm kinh nghiệm thì
mới lên được cái chức vụ gì gió mấy ở
lương cao giống như ngành này chẳng hạn
thì
Ừ thì sẽ cảm thấy rất dài nhưng mà sau
bây giờ để mà nói tự nhiên tôi bây giờ
thấy mình đã dậy được mấy năm liền rồi
này mình mấy năm kinh nghiệm lập trình
này nó nhanh lắm
khi mọi thứ cho da trôi qua thời gian
à Thế ăn cho quá nhanh nên là thứ nhất
là không nên để lãng phí thời gian không
nên ngày ngày kiểu để ý xem mà kiểu mình
mình theo cái này có đáng hay không Vân
vẫn phải thử vẫn này trải nghiệm những
thứ đã vào đừng có đắn đo gì nhiều tuổi
trẻ vẫn nên cống hiến nó thứ
và không nên tự ti về kiểu kiểu Thằng
con nhà người ta thì nó đã học trình từ
bé rồi bây giờ mình bắt đầu học thì có
nhiều người còn có kiểu dạng là vị trí
xuất phát họ khác nhau mà đúng không
quan trọng là kiểu ai kia Kiên nhẫn ở
hơn ấy kiên định rồi cái mục tiêu của
mình hơn thôi không nghĩ là như thế
thí sinh nhật em à hồ xanh đấy tôi sẽ
tặng ông thêm cái cơ nhá
họp ở Sài Gòn hả anh đúng rồi off ở Hồ
Chí Minh đi anh có xe Đức đưa rước không
ạ Có
sẽ tổ chức ở F2 O3 không biết ở đâu ở
trong Sài Gòn nhưng mà nói chung là tuần
sau tôi sẽ đăng for mà
Ừ tôi sẽ băng form chỗ để mà các bạn
đăng ký thì lần này Thực ra thì à
Thì cậu nói chung là chắc là tôi đang
Phong Ký các bạn sẽ nắm rõ được toàn bộ
nội dung kế hoạch là trưởng khung chương
trình tha thứ mọi thứ sau Nhưng mà ở ở
chia sẻ một tí đó là đầu tiên thì lúc
đầu tôi bảo miễn phí đấy Sau đó thì bởi
vì để chắc chắn là số lượng chắc chắn
được số lượng đi không để đăng ký cho
vui đó như là nên gọi là thu phí để mà
nắm chắc được số lượng nhưng mà cái việc
thu phí ở đây thì tôi sẽ xảy ra nó không
hả đắt rồi kìa nó 50.000 50.000 đây
nhưng mà nói thẳng là 50.000 đấy chính
là tự mình hôm quà không biết ông bởi vì
à 50.000 đấy sẽ bao gồm cả sticker với
hai khẩu trang in hình cute im scared
ông nhiên là sẽ hình tin rồi có thể
click gì đó đấy Ờ
Ê bà cái đấy không nằm trong
bảo đâu có sẽ con được xe đưa đón này có
ở bên FPT đã tài trợ về khoản xe đưa đón
địa điểm xong rồi à dây đeo vừa rồi mấy
thợ được thông báo là hình như có cả dây
đeo Nếu không được tặng dây đeo em về
tôi rất thích dây đeo mẹ ạ sưu tầm đấy
Xong rồi còn gì nhỉ ờ giveaway rất nhiều
rất nhiều vừa rồi lại vừa có thêm nhà
tài trợ song tiếp theo có gì nhỉ à
cái gì à
ờ ờ đúng rồi còn tin fake nữa nói cho
mấy ông Chẳng tốn đồng nào cho mấy ông
đấy mấy ông à 50.000 mấy ông bỏ ra cốt
là để đặt được cái chỗ cho cậu gần như
thế mà tự gọi là tự bỏ tiền ra để mua
được hãy nên nhớ là toàn bộ những cái đồ
của Triều Tiên bắn phần VI tim từ trước
đến nay gần như không bán lẻ ở ngoài
không bán mở bán ở ngoài mà đi offline
với phát và mới bán kiểu như này nên là
mấy ông thì ông tôi khuyên với ông mà
nên nếu mà muốn Giả sử là
mấy ông không thiết tha gì đi họp nhưng
mà Mấy ông muốn quà như Tín thì mới Hùng
vẫn phải đặt
thì vào Sài Gòn thực tập đưa hai triệu
để sau này phát triển trong Sài Gòn được
không được cho em Sài Gòn vẫn là dưới
tiềm năng để phát triển các thứ ổn Đấy
rất nhiều cơ hội
ông thầy chia sẻ nhiều câu chuyện truyền
cảm hứng hay quá Tôi không biết được
Bởi vì thực ra là tôi kiểu muốn chia sẻ
các bạn các bạn nó nghe đôi khi nó hơi
bị lên đốt hơi bị xáo rỗng tí nhưng mà
tôi mà chia sẻ câu chuyện của tôi Thực
ra nó nghe nó vẫn giả tạo ý tôi sẽ lấy
minh chứng rõ ràng
người thật việc thật ở xung quanh ta thì
các bạn cảm thấy à Lê Thị Thơ ca thì mới
các bạn cũng có thể bảo là đấy Trẻ một
trong số ít thôi ạ anh ạ nhưng mà tôi
gặp thì cũng rất nhiều rồi
Ê bà bà Bảy tiện thể tôi chia sẻ cái á
chương trình này ở đây ngoài việc chương
trình ở trên cái kênh đấy có sắc anh này
gần đây tôi xem thêm cả cái này
sân nhà triệu đô này
Ừ thì tôi không nói việc là trên đầy nó
nó về các bạn nó chương trình truyền
hình do gì nóng sẽ có tí diễn và
tạo lắm thì cái tính trong đấy các thứ
thứ tôi không đề cập này mấy vụ đấy
nhưng mà những cái lời khuyên của ban
giám khảo và cả những cái trải nghiệm
trong đấy nó vẫn có tính thực tế và nó
khá là hay nói chung mà nó vẫn có rơ hay
để mà xem các thứ cho dù là không liên
quan đến ngành mình nhưng mà xem để mà
kiểu
cho tôi tôi nghĩa ở
chứ không phải là kiểu mình chỉ chăm chú
và xe mỗi hình ảnh của mình đôi khi mình
cũng phải có cuộc sống bên ngoài mình sẽ
xem rất nhiều cái thứ ở bên ngoài học
hỏi thêm nhiều cái đúng không ạ rồi Ít
ra có thêm thì kiến thức Thế ngồi chém
gió tán gái thằng ạ bên cái
ông bị ngồi mũi nói mãi về cốt về với
con gái
ấy thì
Ừ
cái
này mày cái câu chuyện mà tôi chia sẻ
tôi Chị hi vọng kiểu nó sẽ là một cái
gợi ý để cho mấy ông có thể cậu xem tham
khảo
em chưa Tôi cũng không nghĩ à Bây giờ
nói thẳng là ai cũng lớn rồi tôi không
thể dạy đời đừng mấy ông ấy mấy cái này
được hả bảo là kiểu dạy mấy ông gỗ đã
cấp 1 nghe tam giác hoặc là gì đó chứ
Còn bây giờ thì mỗi ông có cái tôi riêng
có kiến thức riêng có khi là mấy ông còn
dành đời hơn tôi tôi không dám cậu lên
lớp mấy nhưng mà tôi vẫn sẽ chia sẻ góc
nhìn của tôi kênh kênh cái này cậu kênh
măng tính chất giống kiểu của lóc mà nó
sẽ có chia sẻ góc nhìn mình ai cảm thấy
gọi là cũng dễ nghe đi
Hì hì thì có thể nghe và đương nhiên là
vẫn nên góp ý thôi ta vẫn rất thích được
mấy ông góp ý cả tiêu cực cổ tích cực
đều được
mục tiêu cực thì da càng tốt để mà tôi
cảm thấy mình cần phải sửa chỗ nào
Ờ Ờ chắc là xin nhận lỗi à Chẳng biết
dùng từ nghèo thì lại khá là
có vài nhóm gần đây có bảo với tôi đó là
đó là kiểu em anh em làm xong cái tài
liệu rồi nhưng mà em khi không biết được
thuyết trình cái đoạn mà sơ đồ chụp thẻ
như thế nào thì thực tế thực tế là tôi
dậy cho mấy ông sơ đồ thể Nó là kiểu rất
là cơ bản nó thẳng là nó tối giản và nó
nếu mà nếu mà sắc khe thì có thể dùng từ
nó không đúng vì
anh Bởi vì thiếu
thiếu thì sẽ có thể dịch ra không đúng
nếu mà là sửa kiểu khắt khe như thế dùng
từ không đúng là như nào để tôi thử giải
thích cho mấy ông nhá
cho ví dụ là mẹ tôi sẽ ví dụ cho mấy ông
thẳng luôn đi
em tính nhà tội còn lí do nó tôi biết
cái này từ trước rồi nhưng mà tại sao
tôi dậy như thế thì tôi sẽ thử nói mấy
ông ạ
nó sẽ như này sẽ có các anh Titi đây
đúng không
cái À thấy bồ đúng không
anh không
anh buồn
anh NTT chứ Đấy học theo dạng là bây giờ
à
sau một entity đỡ đây là Order
Khi bữa trước tôi chỉ dạy mày ông cách
nối Nó là kiểu dạng là nhiều nhiều với
thằng này là được many-to-many nha đúng
trước đúng không ạ như này
cho nó rồi tôi sẽ bảo mấy ông là thế này
tương đối đủ rồi và bảo mấy ông cậu về
ghi thêm những cái cột vào trong này gọi
là những thuộc tính ATP ở trong này
trước bia ở trong này Đâm trước đấy thì
khi cài thuốc ra Lát nó chiếu tại sao
thiếu Bởi vì nếu mà như này thì đôi khi
ông không biết khi màu nhìn vào cái này
người khác nhìn vào ngày người ta sẽ
không hình dung được cái thứ nhất thứ
hai đó khi ông nhìn vào cái ông không
thích trình được nên là bây giờ chắc là
tôi xin phép là tôi sẽ dạy cho ông bé
ông hoàn chỉnh hơn để mấy ông sửa lại và
xong đồ ăn mấy ông để hôm tới bảo vệ thì
sẽ bảo vệ một cách mấy ông cũng dẫn lòng
máy và sẽ không bị bắt bẻ gì cả để một
cách trọn vẹn nhất tại sao tôi lại dạy
theo kiểu như này mà không phải như kia
thì có lý do cả và việc thằng kia cái
thôi đầu tôi dậy thì nó rất là phức tạp
mà nó rất là dễ rối nên tôi sẽ dạy cho
tối ra như thế này còn dậy hai cửa chuẩn
thì nó sẽ như thế này
thì con sẽ là nó sẽ
vì nó liên quan đến thuê xuân ở đây này
thì
nó sẽ là ví dụ là Bình Long thuộc về này
11 sản phẩm thuộc về
rất nhiều Đây đúng chết giờ sẽ là
à à
em gà nối qua cái này chắc là không hẳn
đúng lắm đâu nếu kiểu nhé
em đã nghe nó phải nói thằng ngày ngày
thôi thằng này thằng này trông nó hợp lý
hơn sẽ kiểu đi nghe nhé
có cái hình này mới đúng đấy à
em chụp kiểu ngay tức kiểu ngay đi bra
đó
tin tức là sao một sản phẩm thuộc nhiều
hóa đơn mà ngược lại một hóa đơn có
nhiều sản phẩm thì có thể hát sửa được
nhưng mà có thể ghi nghe sẽ hiểu thì cái
này bạn chất nó thêm các bạn sẽ bảo ừ
rồi anh làm thế mà cứ tưởng nghiêm trọng
kiểu thêm một cái chữ này để để mà khẳng
định thêm cái có cái gì đâu ra là sai
riêng ngày này và nó nối thêm những cái
CPU nữa thì giống như là nếu mà như này
để tạo đúng giống Trên trường có dạy
trường sẽ vài trường các bạn học thì
cũng sẽ có dậy kỹ hơn về mấy cái vụ này
nhưng mà tôi không muốn dậy hơn cả lấy
cái gì nó bị bị hiểu nó bị rối quá khi
mấy ông nhìn vào nhưng mà Đúng là bây
giờ đúng là bây giờ thì có vài bạn hỏi
tôi cả là và bạn ấy vẫn chưa hình triệu
được thì tôi nghĩ à Vậy tối giảm Thế bạn
ấy cũng khó hiểu nghĩa thời gian đầu
đoán một thì tôi dậy tối giản thì các
bạn thấy hiểu chị còn đoán hay thì đúng
à Nó bị nhiều hơn mà dậy những kiểu tối
giản thì đúng là các bạn đang không hiểu
à Chắc là tôi sẽ phải sửa lại là ra đây
các bạn vẫn đúng rồi nhá Không cần sửa
lại với tao bay không sợ lại Cốc gì cả
mà chỉ là phải sở lại thực thể để mà
mình hình dung được hơn và mình nói được
hơn
Ê mấy ông hiểu tao mạng tại thêm nhóm
nào mà hôm nay tôi hi vọng tất cả nhóm
Hôm nay có xem để mà để mà xem lại sửa
lại cái Cụ thể hôm sau còn dễ dễ phát
biểu đây thì tôi tiếp tục nói nhé Nếu mà
mày ông mà nhìn vào đây để mà xinh
elotop ai thì chắc chắn là mấy ông sẽ
chưa có một cái thằng bảng trung gian
lưu lại mã của hai thằng này hết Không
có gì cả bể rõ ràng trên màn chất ở đây
ăn Chi Pu là Cắt cụt của cô đắp và các
cột của order có đầy đủ rồi Nhưng mà cái
này bản trung gian thì nó chỉ có cột và
cột mã mã ngủ bảng này và mát Mà này làm
gì có gì thêm đúng ạ Đấy do mình sẽ phải
sinh ra một thằng nữa nó là như này mình
sẽ phải nổi ACB vào
cài đặt núi này nó mới gọi là mệt này
chắc phải ngồi nối nối mệt thật cả nhà
rất là sao Bây giờ các bạn thế à Hồi đấy
là mình ví dụ là cái cái mối quan hệ này
mình sẽ là kiểu dặm mà con đời đi theo
là hóa đơn chi tiết đây là ông ạ
chị Hà thì nó sẽ có là cậu thêm cột giá
nó chẳng hạn thịt dai ở đây này Đấy là
Thiện Chipu tức là cột đấy nhá
các bạn sẽ hiểu như thế
Anh tên thêm kèo giá ở đây này hỏi ta
thêm về số lượng và đây nữa chẳng hạn
thế
I want it I
t2k
cái không Lúc tôi cho copy hai cách con
Ti đó như này thì mấy ông Khi mà xinh
nha tao bay mình không sẽ hoàn toàn xin
là được nghĩa là thằng bạn trung gian nó
sẽ có thêm hai cái cột mày nữa đấy thì
bây giờ mấy ông mà ngồi làm lại tao bay
thì mới ông sẽ thấy Ui ngồi ghi hết toàn
bộ quần áo cô ta xong rồi nuôi nối hiểu
ngay vừa mất nó đúng à hơi mất công thật
em mất công đi không đúng để nó không
phí không dùng tới mất công được mà nó
tốn cậu nó cái ổ cũng ốm lằng nhằng và
trông mà bị rối Có nhưng mà nhớ bù lại
thì
Ừ thì Thế mợ cái số lô thể chuột bởi vì
solo kẻ nó xinh anticipate tôi nhắc đi
nhắc lại đi lấy rồi thì phải có những
cái này thì nó mới sinh ra được cái bảng
có hai cột này đúng không Chứ nếu mà tự
nhiên có belonged to tự nhiên 2 cột này
nó chui cho ra đúng không Mình tưởng đi
làm đúng không Nghĩa là rõ ràng mình
phải ghi đầy đủ tất cả các thực thể
thuộc tính của nó từ thứ thôi để mà khi
tao bay mình sẽ có
à mình mình mình mới ra được đâu Tao đây
đúng ạ ấy thì cái này Nói chung là các
bạn sẽ phải sửa lại cái solok mà nhóm
nào mà cảm thấy là sửa khó quá thì có
thể
mình sẽ gọi trao đổi Ghi âm nhưng mà
ngồi sửa chị chỉ sửa lại các bạn này cái
vụ này thì để hôm tối mình bảo vệ bảo vệ
ở đây Tại sao tự nhiên tôi đấy tôi thứ
nhất là đỡ nhà tôi tôi thấy có gì không
một thì tôi sẽ phải nhận sai và tội sửa
đương nhiên là nóng sẽ có ảnh hưởng các
thứ thứ Ừ nhưng mà quan trọng là mình
mình bỏ qua cái tồi mình phải nhận sai
đã đúng không mà mình tìm cách khắc phục
cái thứ tự thứ hai đó là đó là kiểu
chúc các thầy có thầy chủ yếu lại là các
thầy ở đại học nên thành ra các thầy lý
thuyết tới ở nặng nề là sẽ đòi họ rất
khắt khe về những cái này nghĩa cốt các
bạn thì các thầy không quan tâm lắm mà
cốt các bạn kiểu tối ưu như thế nào và
có xịn như nào cùng những cái thư viện
gì không quan trọng bằng việc ở lý
thuyết các bạn phải rất là chắc đấy
nhưng mà đương nhiên mà Đấy là các thầy
và thực tế đi ra ngoài là thì nói thẳng
nói thẳng nhé đó là phải đến phải đến
quá nửa số người tôi biết không biết
cách thiết kế ra tờ bời chứ đừng nó là
là làm cái sơ đồ hệ này chuột
anh đào tạo bây ở Hưng Yên sinh kể cậu
các thử thứ và không nằm chắc các thứ
câu Apple sẽ biến mức cơ bản cơ bản nữa
nhé chứ bảo ai ba bà Nội lên bê tông đi
hẳn sang có công ty khác công thứ họ xem
bảo người ta về cách xử lý các thứ do 3
4 bảng trở lên xem người ra xử lý một
cái như thế nào khẳng định luôn là rất
ít nơi có biết biết rồi à anh em để mày
có bộ em mấy anh em có thể chuyên thuật
toán có nhưng mà mẹ anh em lại không
nghĩ ra tôi bay đâu bể sao Bởi vì tao
bay thường mà là sẽ có một vài người phụ
trách vụ đấy như từng nói rồi trừ khi
công ty rất là bé mình full sách mà mình
làm hết thôi đấy thứ nhất thứ hai đó là
tôi rất thích về cơ sở liệu thì tôi mới
dậy sâu mấy ông ấy vụ đấy chứ còn và thở
ra nó cũng là một cái tốt nếu mà ông mà
giỏi cái này thì ông sẽ tự khiến bản
thân ông Có rất có giá trị về như tôi
vừa nói quá nữa anh em kia không biết về
cơ sở hữu tự nhiên không biết như ông ở
dạng là ông
về mặt mũi sáng sủa hơn nếu không ấy rồi
ý nghĩa nhỉ Đấy thì à
anh chị học sinh à Ừ chị khan nữa ờ
ừ ừ
Ừ thì tôi đang ngồi ở đâu nhỉ
Ừ thì nói chung là kiểu Tôi nghĩ là ta
bây giờ là quan trọng dữ liệu luôn luôn
quan trọng nên là kiểu đừng có chạy theo
cái bịch đã ta à nhầm nhầm big data sẽ
tới bây rồi đừng chạy nhờ ai đừng chạy
được Toàn thuật toán cao siêu làm gì
trong khi đó những cái mà bản chất là
mua Vỹ do trước mai nó mãi vẫn thế đó
chính là cơ sở liệu thì các bạn phải
chuyên nó đã trước khi mà kiểu cơ hàm
nhảy theo công nghệ mới có rất nhiều
người hạn hàm nhảy theo công nghệ mới
xong rồi Kiểu những câu FeO cơ bản không
biết tôi thấy nó cái gì buồn cười của gì
kiểu chuyện với ai Nhưng mà gặp kiểu
dạng chỉ biết về mỗi thuật toán đấy anh
em
à à Con gì nhé bạn kia hỏi có khắc đồ
không ờ ờ
à Tôi đang định ngồi kiểm tra code và
nói chung nhà tôi tôi sẽ thông báo Tôi
sẽ định thông báo bên đi cân của tôi để
xem các bạn Hazard thích năm nay ở tham
gia nhưng mà thấy hận thực ra không quan
trọng lắm về các bạn hát rồi đấy
tự như ông ấy số lượng người xem đông
khi mà ông run hơn nhưng mà nhưng mà
chắc chắn là các bạn hát hết ở đây đều
sẽ rất là muôn kiểu tuyển với ông rồi
khẳng định thế luôn
Một bể cá ông lang gần như biết làm rồi
mà Đây là kiểu gì cũng sẽ inbox không
Cái thứ và tôi có đăng cái gì đi mày ông
thích thì mày ông tự ứng tiền đấy đúng
không ạ Ở nhắc thế Cái trang web kia nó
đang còn chưa lên cơ trang web về không
còn còn phải xem
đã test tổng lại con thứ và à Gọi Đăng
bài lại cho cẩn thận đã
xã hộigiải đang quá bận để đổi cốt ở đấy
mà thực ra B ở khung cốt được làm tập
trung chữa cho mấy ông rồi đó xong đã
Vì sao web lấy rồi phải sang tháng mà
sáng tháng nữa cơ căng thẳng quá nhiều
thứ tôi bận
em bận thật
anh em ấy ông thấy đấy vừa rồi vẫn còn
phải nhắn tin liên tục xong rồi à Còn
nhắn vừa Zalo của telegram rồi Một đống
tác của tôi ở đây liên qua đến đang buổi
offline
khi dạy các cách bitroi wifi ở trên mạng
có rất nhiều nhưng mà sẽ có hôm đó Khi
mà tôi biết lo cái kia tôi sẽ chia sẻ
với ông sao nhưng mà đợi hôm đấy Nó hơi
xa
Nam miễn phí mấy ông cứ đẩy lên đấy nhé
ok Nói chung là bây giờ mình sẽ xin phép
chữa đoán Qua của nhóm 21 51 đảm bảo là
chưa qua về tài liệu ạ
nữa thì phải
mày ông xác nhận ở trên ít hấp là là
tương đồng ấy rất nhiều thứ miễn phí hay
phết trước tôi vừa xem vọng nó còn miễn
phí cả tới miền cơ
cho miễn phí Mình tên 11 năm nhỉ
U21
có rất nhiều À đấy là mai mà không có
lên đó à đấy có vô trách bốn là tôi tồn
tại bên đồ thì thôi
ở bên đó là cái thư mục của mục thư các
thư viện đấy bao gồm cả thư mục thư viện
E với
ô kê
miền thì nó là miễn phí tên miền nhưng
mà hút sinh đôi nhớ cũng có đấy
ở ngõ 28 Ok Vậy anh đi phải đăng nhập
đăng ký trong trẻo nhỉ
a mã
không
a a nhắn đăng nhập ít hấp tự nhiên nó bị
treo
ừ ừ
à à
Và
như thế Tôi tắt hết hết ngày điện đỡ đâu
ô tô Candy
à à
áo vét ao Canada
ừ ừ
phim hài
ở tập bớt đi à
ở tuổi Tuất hết đi rồi bà lại
miễn phí nhưng về các bạn nó hàng mất
tiền
với cô đâu Đừng hi vọng gì đó
có lại code for nó mới lên
anh nhé
Bài học rút lại rồi
cung cấp độc quyền nhỉ
ô
tô hôm nay
Ồ tôi thích ở phân quyền lại mệt ghê
cơ
- vãi
à à
tp Storm II
tay vợt sang control
Có ai đi hát đây
thế này rồi mà đi và
xe lửa
à à
nói anh yêu anh Ok Ok em
anh xóa
ở xã này
anh xóa hết rồi
à à
Ừ
được rồi
Ồ không tôi rút lại câu rồi
ừ Địt gái chưa
Translate này
Ừ thứ thử đây đó ngon 10 cái này không
cho xem ok đủ
xem cho xem
đây để
a version
có ghi tắt bếp đâu nhỉ cần ăn đêm nhé
vẫn dùng được ít
nếu tôi còn mới cập nhật cái á cái này
lên mới nhất rồi đấy
thực hiện ra luôn
Ừ sáng nay đi nha
Em hát bài này
à à
anh alo
Sự thật luôn
mới quá
Ừ ông gửi tại tôi cái link tôi vào xem
trực tiếp vậy
đi tạm Bỏ qua Bộ này đi thôi Thế xử lý
vụ này sao
em tự mình làm một cái wep thì bắt đầu
học từ đâu ạ
anh dậy làm web có cái clip cơ bản rồi
đấy
ờ ờ
cái link ký thấp nhé
anh ở đây
chồng bãi trộn thế
Ừ
thế Download hẳn về đi
em đi lấy đồ rồi này mình có quyền đi
lấy ạ à
nhỉ
à à
Em hãy Download kiểu thế
khi mở xem cho mày
bóp của tôi một phát được luôn đấy mẹ
nói chậm
Ừ ông chết tới trận quá xa luôn
mạnh tôi vẫn đủ cho
so với hồi hồi trước là nó là cao nhất
của hộ gia đình Bây giờ tôi nhận có đề
nghị gọi cao cấp hơn rồi nha Mà nó hơn
400.000 1 tháng năm rưỡi vậy Một mình
dùng
thế quán quá xịn cho một người
giao diện ở trong ngày
cái mục lục bài đó không
nhỉ ở Quản lý giờ học
Em tự học này họ
chương trình tự xử lý không có trình
thực xử lý là em vẫn chưa điên Các phần
chính tớ xử lý
nhà anh đang mở bằng cái khác
sao
[âm nhạc]
nhiều phết nặng phết đấy
dự báo thường anh thông báo cho cả lớp
thì hơn
anh ở đây là theo từng lớp từng sinh
viên nhạc ok ok
cô bé lớp này lớp đăng ký học bổ túc
kiểu lấy gì vậy
này chắc là bỏ qua thôi một tài liệu này
cần xem à Tao hiểu ơi trước mũi thế này
chưa biết phân tích Kali
tôi thử cái ghi nhầm cái này nhá gì chứ
gj chữ gì ở không biết hoa chứ quy trình
viên mãn
à à
khi Microsoft thực các thứ thuế
nhọn nằm trong cái lưu ý hơn
về lý thuyết lens
thế này chưa rõ lắm
Ừ cái này phải là lợi ích đấy mã của
người đang đăng nhập để mà
Ừ chứ chứ hơi kiểu này thì nó hơi bị
chung chung quá đấy mã người đăng nhập
xong rồi lấy ra từ bảng nào bạn nào thì
nó ổn hơn thằng nghe nó hợp lý hơn
anh nói xong rồi lấy thông tin từ bảng
nào ra các thứ thì nó mới chuẩn với cái
trình tự ghi đầy đủ hơn về cái trình tự
trước ghi cả này thì nó bị chung chung
quá không hiểu lắm
như thế nào thì mày cũng phải đề cập rõ
ra
ở một con nhận bài không đi khá dài rồi
về ngủ sữa mày đấy
vì lý do wed của tôi ai như nào
thử ngay ổn này ok ok chuẩn này U1 N1 n
có thể thử không
hồ sơ đồ trang web P
đoạn này
a boy nếu mới làm chưa nhỉ e55 passport
chưa
chưa làm Powerpoint đúng không Ok
ở nhóm 28 nhỉ
anh cho xem
của bạn này nữa
à à
u não
Hồ Ngọc Phi chủ nhật à
add a comment
ở sân bay
Ừ ok
Ừ
tôi sẽ mở cho cái đoạn đi Sau đó lên xem
cái
à à
anh em mấy ông bị nhược điểm thế này Thế
tiêu đề này nó cái to hơn ngày nay phải
nổi bật hơn
không nên dùng word để gõ mà dùng qua đó
Đấy nó sẽ gợi ý lỗi chính tả hợp việc đã
nó sẽ thỉnh thoảng nó sẽ có đề xuất với
cái mục lục giữa hai thì sẽ một bộ quà
xong rồi đấy
3 cách để tạo mục lục vì nó kiểu không
biết tôi tưởng chỉ với ông chưa kiểu như
này
rõ gì đó sớm điện nói chủ đề này cái nó
sẽ luôn có cài Online cũng cái sườn lai
đây này hay này tiếp theo là chủ đề bé
hơn thì sẽ hết pin này tính tình này họ
đã gia đình là tùy các bạn các bạn đâu
như có thể chỉnh có thể
em có thể tự mình thay đổi phong cách nó
xong rồi Các bạn chọn update heading nó
khớp của cái phong cách đấy thì nó sẽ có
cái online như này đỡ đầu
chính tả nữa đến hình hiển thị hiển thị
giống vừa nãy
này cũng
Anh cũng hiểu mà không đang định mở
bí ẩn nhưng thực ra nó cũng chỉ nên ăn
chuyển mã giáp xử lý mà đắt không có cái
gì hơn
ông đại vẫn trẻ Isaac tam giác tam giác
mà
Em hãy lưu ý thêm chưa nhỉ À đấy có thêm
lưu ý Ok rồi
đây ok
3 bài tập trung hết xử lý ở bên lưu ý ạ
Cũng được à
thông qua
cũng được cho bạn ấy cũng gọi là phân
tích các thứ thứ II
a fairly Bạn ghi hết rồi toàn bộ phần
lưu ý luôn à
ý thì cái sơ đồ thể nhóm này thì chữa
lại cái này giống như còn anh bảo thì sẽ
dễ hiểu hơn nha
A BOY của nhóm máy XANH sau đó thì các
bạn tham khảo thương mình không thể chấm
hết được
à à Thằng này bắt phải trả đi Cái Thế
thì mình lại dùng ạ like cho mình đã lên
thôi
hôm nay là
các bạn dùng cái kể chuyện à
anh cày phim người ông đôi khi phải
crack
khi tổn thương thứ công nghệ này xong
rồi phân tích qua từng người làm gì đại
khái giống đoán một thôi mà ok Ổn
Em chỉ cần thế này đâu mà
có miễn phí nha Tôi nói cho tôi không
biết cày thôi
hàm Google hơn vì nó kiểu nó lưu vậy hết
sẵn ở trên trên web cho mình dễ lấy mình
dễ truy cập bằng điện thoại cứ như là
đứng như là bây giờ thằng mai có shop
cũng có nhớ tôi lần cuối cho xe bị nó
phải tài khoản gì ấy
số tài khoản đã kích hoạt kia như thế nó
mới cậu nó mới đồng bộ
em muốn thắc mắc thì buổi hôm nay tôi
thấy là khá ổn ý nhá là mấy hai nhóm còn
nhóm nào cầm tôi chữa chấm nữa thì có gì
thì kệ Bảo với tôi để tôi
- tôi sẽ chữa cho các nhóm đấy Không thì
mình tặng kết thúc đấy nhỉ
Ừ thế còn ấy ra hai nhóm này hôm đấy bảo
vệ hôm thứ Bảy có vẻ là sẽ bảo vệ được
anh ta cần thêm hai ngon nữa thôi cũng
được là ổn không cần phải đông vài nhóm
Hôm nay bảo vệ thôi là ngon anh rồi
em nói bữa mày cho tạm ngừng đây nha các
bạn nha
à à